remember my song waiting for tonight  yeah well it has a different meaning now  that I'm getting older I can't wait to  lock it home to put my PJs on and crawl  into bed and fight forever and for  tonight Oh  when half-foot [ __ ] inside my bed  waiting for tonight waiting for tonight  mark don't give the kids junk food no  candy no orioles no gigabits I mean it  mark and don't give them a cigarette I  know you still smoke you look like a  Danny Elfman character Tim Burton wait  mark mark  have you watched shades of blue what do  you think it's a good show yeah I'm  performing in Vegas tonight so I better  rehearse my songs I'm still I'm still  Jenny from the block it's got a little  got a little lot  I'm still I'm still Jenny from the block  the other night my friend Kim Kardashian  came to my show in Vegas and gave me a  birthday cake sweetheart would it  sweetheart I don't know why I had such  trouble blowing out my candles on the  cake I went they didn't blow up